also breaking tonight for subpoenas have
been issued to IRS and FBI investigators
involved in the hunter Biden probe here
now to explain house ways and means
committee chairman Jason Smith along
with house Judiciary Committee chairman
Jim Jordan both by the way are
responsible for the subpoenas Jim Jordan
before I get to that plan a no charges
Plan B sweetheart deal that a judge blew
up to the shock of everybody
that Weiss Works side by side with
Hunter's
brother Beau Biden Joe's son Politico
Hunter's lawyers threatened the White
House Joe's going to have to testify and
then Hunters Hunters lawyers demanding
the doj prosecute the whistleblowers I'm
betting you have a lot to say about this
yeah the idea that Joe Biden's going to
testify is ridiculous can you imagine
putting Joe Biden on the stand right now
and him facing cross-examination I mean
there's no way that's going to happen
but this was the pressure campaign they
were putting on the doj and John's
Solomon's exactly right but for these
whistleblowers that sweetheart deal
would have been even sweeter they
weren't even going to require Hunter
Biden plead guilty to anything that this
is how this is how bad this was and what
we want to do Sean is we want to talk to
the folks who were in the meeting these
whistleblowers come forward they changed
history as John Solomon just pointed out
what prompted them to come forward this
meeting October 7th 2022 you got David
Weiss you got Gary shapley The
Whistleblower and four other people in
that meeting we want to talk to those
four other people because that's the
meeting that Gary shapley said that was
the red line meeting when I decided
there was no way this investigation was
going to do the right thing we had to
come forward and talk to Jason Smith
chairman Smith's team at the at the Ways
and Means Committee and then they came
forward and their test testimony unlike
the White House's story unlike the doj
their testimony has stood up and they've
appeared entirely credible throughout
this ordeal Jason Smith yeah these
whistleblowers spoke to your committee
the house weighs the Means Committee uh
what's your reaction to Hunter's lawyer
is demanding that the doj prosecute
those whistleblowers especially after
listening to Joe Biden praising
whistleblowers but that was the hearsay
whistleblower that was against Donald
Trump
one thing about it Sean when these IRS
whistleblowers came before the the house
Ways and Means Committee their stories
has completely stayed the same but the
information that they've released was
shocking to members of Congress and it
was shocking to the American public but
Sean you know who was not shocked about
their information was the Department of
Justice because in fact the Department
of Justice Just as the whistleblowers
highlighted they used numerous tactics
that delayed the investigation to such a
degree that the statute of limitations
expired for some of the most egregious
crimes of 2014 and 15 tax years they
they denied prosecution which is why we
want to know about this October 7th
meeting and why we've subpoenaed more
individuals to answer our questions and
they divulged information to Hunter
Biden's lawyers if if the whistleblowers
wouldn't have came forward we wouldn't
have known those aspects and they
definitely they definitely change
history all right Jim Jordan I want you
to talk about the subpoenas that you
you're committee the Judiciary in the
ways of Means Committee uh to the IRS
and to the FBI from today and do you
think something's going on here with the
New York Times Politico The Washington
Post and even even Chucky Todd and and
leftwingers like him are now saying he's
got a big problem
what does that tell you yeah they see
the evidence piling up they see they see
The credibility of these whistleblowers
and they see what was reported this week
you know the story in Politico the story
in the New York Times I thought there
was all kinds of interesting things in
there decided they were going to make
Biden testify that they wanted to go
after the whistleblowers but what really
struck me and it ties into what John was
just saying is that in 2019 Hunter
Biden's legal team wanted to meet with
him to talk about things and he said I
can't meet that day because I'm talking
with the impeachment lawyers so is he
talking with Daniel Goldman the lawyer
for Adam Schiff is he talking with who's
he talking to because it was all about
Barista and as John pointed out they
said one thing the Biden team said one
thing the Democrats said one thing but
the document shows something else they
show that President Trump was on the
right track so that is definitely an
Avenue that we're going to explore as
well in our investigation but right now
it's the focus on that meeting that red
line meeting according to whistleblower
shapley where he said David Weiss told
them he didn't have the authority that
Merrick Garland and David Weiss were
saying they had and that's when he knew
we have to go to Congress we have to
become whistleblowers we have to tell
the story so the American people get the
truth about how wrong this investigation
was uh was being handled Jason leftward
I I would absolutely agree you look at
what the activity of Hunter Biden's
lawyers were they they're the same
people who told the Department of
Justice prosecutors that if they bring
charges against Hunter Biden they'd be
facing career suicide and now they're
threatening the President coming and
testifying it's outrageous all right
thank you both hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else